[Music]
thank you
one of the particularly important
characters in Philip K Dick's novel The
Man in the High Castle is a middle-aged
Japanese trade official named uh
nobosuke tagome typically referred to by
his last name in the story and we see a
lot of things through his eyes and his
interactions he's also centrally
important to the plot he winds up saving
the day when there's an attack on the
Nippon Times building that we'll talk
about later but I think the most
important aspect is that more than
anybody else he provides something like
a moral perspective that may be that of
the author to some degree for what is
going on in the world of the the novel
and he's a complex person I have to
admit as well that through my many
re-readings of this novel he has come to
be my personal favorite character so
there's a lot to say about him and the
beginning of the novel doesn't actually
tell us that much about this yet he's in
the very very first scene to a certain
degree
tagomi is there is is talking with
children
and he says did my Civil War recruiting
poster arrive yet sir please recall you
promised at some time last week the
fussy brisk voice barely polite barely
keeping the code did I not give you a
deposit Sir Mr children with that
stipulation this is to be a gift you see
I explained that a client and then you
know he says it has not arrived yet I
can wait no further more and he's kind
of been pulling rank on on Sheldon both
um in terms of culture and race and in
terms of the client Patron relationship
and he's he's looking for a gift and
he's concerned with this meeting that is
coming up with somebody who appears to
be a businessman Barnes arriving to talk
about injection molding and Plastics
which is quite important for the
Japanese coming from Sweden this is
going to turn out to be quite different
than
it's first appearing right
and he is concerned with this meeting
that he's going to have
um he says you know no matter what Mr
Children came up with the client would
probably not be impressed let us face
that he said to himself at least we can
keep him from being displeased we can
refrain from insulting him by a moldy
gift and he's preparing for this meeting
he's thinking to himself it's essential
to avoid politics he didn't know Mr
Bain's views on leading issues of the
day right and he actually consults the
Oracle to figure out will this this
connection between him and Mr Children
who's providing the Americana gifts will
this actually be useful and so this we
see the very first
encounter with the Oracle the book of
changes the eeging that tagomi is going
to rely on at many points and we've
talked about that elsewhere so we don't
have to go into too much of that this
time but we see that he relies on it uh
quite a bit for wisdom and for guidance
and there's you know this reference
within the work itself that it's sort of
like an uh an amalgamation accumulation
of the wisdom of the sage is something
alive and it gives him an indication
about how to approach situations so
before a lot of the encounters that he
has he will in fact engage in the
process of divination later he will use
it to some degree to reintegrate his
self it's it's a way of understanding
the world and his own relation to it a
world that is deeply flawed and there's
even this sense of the Oracle being able
to deal with these Twisted people the
Nazis who control
probably over half of the world and who
have the upper hand when it comes to
their main axis Ally the Japanese empire
and co-prosperity sphere so we see him
uh this is I think particularly
important resorting to the Oracle after
the SD attack right
so this is after tagomi has become sort
of a hero rising to the occasion the SD
the the uh police sort of the the
successor to the Gestapo in this case
are going after Barnes who's actually
Rudolph Wegner who is meeting with this
uh Japanese uh
General to discuss uh a terrible plot
against the Japanese empire that will
result in kind of a world conflagration
and they they invade the building uh
these Commandos and tagomi shoots two of
them with an antique Colt 45 pistol
which he purchased and has been
practicing with and we noticed that
there's this interesting Reflection by
General tadecki and by Bane slash Wagner
right so tadeki says he will recover his
equilibrium in time right now he has no
standpoint by which he can view and
comprehend his act that book The Oracle
will help him for it provides an
external frame of reference
and um Baines is reflecting on this and
he thinks to save one life Mr tagomi had
to take two The Logical balanced mind
cannot make sense so that a kindly man
like Mr tagumi could be driven insane by
the implications of such reality
right and he goes on further General
today he was right time would give Mr
tagomi perspective either that or he
would perhaps Retreat into the shadows
of mental illness avert his gaze forever
due to a hopeless perplexity and
what does tagumi actually thinking
during this
so tagomi is resorting to the Oracle
right here's how it reads whole
situation confusing and anomalous no
human intelligence could decipher it
only 5 000 year old joint mind
applicable German totalitarian Society
resembles some faulty form of life worse
than natural thing worse in all its
admixtures it's potpourri of
pointlessness
and he goes on and he thinks who really
is Germany whoever was almost like
decomposing nightmare parody of problems
customarily faced in course of existence
the Oracle will cut through it even
weird breed of cat-like Nazi Germany
comprehensible to e Ching right now what
we find though two chapters later in
number 14 is that
tagomi feels himself to be abandoned in
a certain way he thought to himself
there is no answer no understanding even
in the Oracle yet I must go on living
day to day anyhow I will go and find the
small live unseen at any rate until
sometime later when and he says goodbye
to his house to his wife leaves the
house and doesn't go to the nipple and
Times building thinks to himself should
I go and relax and he says no I must
clutch at human life perhaps I can never
go back to the Nippon Times building and
its stink of death my career over but
just as well and then he he's you know
thinking about operation dandelion and
he says hopeless wherever one looks the
Oracle enigmatic Perhaps it is withdrawn
from the world of man and sorrow the
sage is leaving we have entered a moment
when we are alone we cannot get
assistance as before well Mr tagomi
thought perhaps that too is good or it
can be made good one must still try to
find the way now this is very
interesting we see him relying on the
Oracle when he can and at actually at
some point saying I should have
consulted the Oracle I've kind of lost
the way in this but he also has inner
resources that he will rely upon and he
knows perhaps because he has an affinity
with it that there is still the
possibility of goodness in the world in
human action in mindsets even though
evil seems to be winning to the degree
that perhaps the oracle all has actually
withdrawn from the world and left them
on their own this is very uh inspiring I
would say and this leads necessarily to
the next main thing that we should talk
about this recognition that he has for
evil and calling it out again why he is
so to speak the moral voice and the
first hint of it that we see here is him
talking with Barnes and asking him as a
Swede for his neutral opinion
criticizing the Germans and he says
we have not in our society solve the
problem of the Aged more of which
persons occur constantly as medical
measures improve China teaches us
rightly to honor the old however the
Germans cause are the Japanese neglect
to seem close to outright virtue I
understand that they murder the old and
he talks about this attitude he says can
you can one take an attitude like this
you're a neutral give me your opinion
and Mr Bain says well I don't understand
what attitude you mean and then here we
get this moral uh
what would we call it conundrum being
posed towards the old the sick the
feeble the insane the useless in all
variations
and he says isn't it true that no man
should be the instrument for another's
need and to go home he says during the
War I held a minor Post in the district
of China there at Hong Kyu a settlement
of Jews interned by the Imperial
government for duration kept Alive by
joint relief the Nazi minister at
Shanghai requested we Massacre the Jews
I remember my superiors answer it was
such is not an accord with humanitarian
considerations they rejected the request
as barbaric it impressed me and Bain
says well I I can't say anything about
it I'm not a German of course he is a
German right and he he thinks a lot
about these sorts of things but this is
quite uh interesting to see how tagomi
is concerned with these matters we see a
similar thing coming up in the briefing
that is going on within his is his
building about the by the foreign office
telling them about
the possible successors in the Nazi
State and we see that as they're
discussing these people Mr tagumi felt
ill as he listened he's having a
physical response to hearing about these
terrible evil people and Mr tagumi at a
certain point
um that thinks I am going mad I have to
get out of here I'm having an attack my
body is throwing up things or spurting
them out I am dying
so he scrambles to his feet gets to the
lavatory several heads turned saw him
humiliation sick at important meeting
lost place
at once the Panic ceased as he gets
through the open door his gaze cease to
swim he saw objects once more and he
thinks think along reassuring lines
recall the order of the world what to
draw in religion he thought
um and then he talks to this other
Embassy employee and then he has this
reflection very important
there is evil it's actual like cement I
can't believe it I can't stand it evil
is not a view all of our religion is
wrong what will I do
so he's trying to sort out what how to
make sense of this and he thinks to
himself it's an ingredient in US
in the world poured over us filtering
into our bodies Minds hearts into the
pavement itself
we're blind moles
excuse me creeping through the soil
feeling with our snoots we know nothing
I perceive this now I don't know where
to go Screech with fear only run away
and so he's having this
existential reaction to the evil that is
taking place and being discussed we see
this again too
talking about operation dandelion in
chapter 12 the arrangement the meeting
that tagomi is just the cover for of a
high-placed military official from the
Japanese side and a
counterintelligence operative from the
Nazi regime revealing these plans to use
nuclear weapons on the Japanese home
islands and the fact that it seems that
the dominant faction after the power
struggle is in favor of this plan
horrific evil that is going to be
visited on things and in order to
counter this they are going to have to
work with as it's described the most
malignant portion of German society and
again tagomi thinks about evil
evil he thought yes it is are we to
assist it in gaining power in order to
save our lives is that the Paradox of
our Earthly situation I cannot face this
dilemma Mr tagomi said to himself that
man should have to act in such moral
ambiguity now notice the reference to
the Oracle here
there is no way in this all is muddled
all chaos of light and dark shadow and
substance
so this is quite revealing as well and
then finally after the attack on the S
uh by the SD on the Napoleon Times
building where tagomi has to take two
lives after he's managed to reintegrate
himself not with the Oracle but the
little piece of Frank's jewelry that
contains
um
he has a confrontation with rice and
they're essentially
talking past each other right he tells
uh rice that you know here we go allow
me to notify you your nation is about to
descend into greater vileness than ever
speaking as a private person not as
representative of Japanese official dumb
I declare heart sick with horror
bloodbath coming beyond all compare yet
even now you strive for some slight
egotistical gain or goal put one on over
on Rival faction uh and he says you know
I am suffering he told hair rise of
malady growing these long ears but which
emerged virulent form the day I heard
helplessly your leaders escapades
recited therapeutic possibility nil for
you too sir in language of Goodman see
Mather if properly recalled repent and
the German Council says properly
recalled and then they're talking about
Frank Fink and his case and actually
tagomi is going to save think in part
because he doesn't want to cooperate
with the evil that the Nazis are doing
and then interestingly
tagomi says conduct future business
through intermediate Machinery such as
mail telephone cable not personally
the council says you're holding me
responsible for General conditions
beyond my jurisdiction and then what
does tagomi says chicken I say that
to that and the council says this is not
the way civilized individuals conduct
business you're making this all bitter
and vindictive where it ought to be mere
formality with no personality embroiled
and tagumi says take foul stinking
cigarette along
now he's
opposing the Nazis and the consul by
doing this but this leads us to another
interesting feature of this
he's very self-aware he he is not
thinking he is the White Knight writing
wrongs resisting evil he's just doing
what he can he tells his Aid you
witnessed repellent childish conduct he
made his way unsteadily back into his
office right and he's thinking to
himself this this is not the way to
handle bad people we also notice him at
several different points condemning
fanaticism he does so with children when
children is telling him about the
jewelry and the New Perspective that it
it offers he's like I don't want to buy
into your Anglo-Saxon fanaticism it's
kind of repellent to me but he also
apologizes to Baines for displaying his
own fanaticism he recognizes this flaw
in himself and I also want to point out
that in the beginning when he's engaging
with Baines Baines calls him up and to
go me thinks to himself oh I offended
him
he must have gathered correctly I
heartily failed to inform my staff about
the Old Gentleman and he he decides you
know it's just a trifle but
indicative of my foolish and factless
attitude Mr tagomi felt guilt and then
he says I should have consulted the
Oracle discovered what the moment is
right so he's he's somebody with a
conscience with some real self-awareness
and our our encounters with tagomi and
as he begins to suffer a heart attack
after his confrontation with Council
rice
um
as he fell he clutched within his coat
the silver triangle thing did not save
me he thought did not help all that
endeavor and he thinks to him he says
I'm having a small heart attack notify
wife please right he hears ambulance
noises and he his ties removed his
collar loosened and he says better now
he lay comfortably not trying to stir
career over anyhow German Consul will no
doubt complain about incivility anyhow
work done as far as I can my part the
rest is up to Tokyo and factions in
Germany and he thinks to himself could
this be the answer the mystery of the
body organism its own knowledge time to
quit or time partially to quit a purpose
which I must acquiesce to what did the
Oracle last said to his query in the
office as those two lay dying or dead
the SD men who he shot 61 Inner truth
pigs and fishes are least intelligent of
all hard to convince
it's I
the book means me I will never fully
understand that is the nature of such
creatures or is this inner truth now
this is happening that is happening to
me
I will wait I will see which it is
Perhaps it is both and with that our
story of Mr tagomi ends in this very
complex narrative